all right so we got the final
installment of the Starcraft 2 series
here it's legacy of the board we got the
collector's edition box here and we're
gonna do a hot unboxing so let's kind of
see what's in it
nice box of course and let's lift up
here and here is the game DVD box if you
don't get the game DVD obviously it
could be digital looks like we got a
legacy of the void soundtrack it has 21
songs one including my life for Eyre
always good and here is a behind the
scenes blu-ray I believe it has like an
hour or more of just behind-the-scenes
footage more like Starcraft and
Starcraft 2 history looks like it could
have a lot of cool and interesting stuff
so that might be worth checking out and
then finally we have this Field Manual
which looks kind of cool it's kind of
see what's in here looks like we have
some kind of cool artwork here's a drone
it's a got some of the its stats and you
know what kind of worker it is what kind
of you know unit type it is let's look
at something else kind of skip ahead
here's some some Protoss history and
Protoss the reticle is what says there
so some more artwork here is a stalker
looking pretty cool there got a dragoon
bringing it back old-school some like
brood wars back in the glory days
good old pylon you need pylons no pylon
you can't build of course a little bit
more ahead oh that's classified and
here's a disruptor one of the newer
units in Starcraft 2 legacy of the void
so that's pretty cool so there's
obviously you know multiple units you
could go through in this field manual
and of course not in the box is some
collectible stuff that you can get
you're gonna get your kind of standard
three Starcraft two portraits
one for each race also it looks like
you're getting an extra skin for the
purifier unit also look it looks like
you're gonna get a Wow pet it's an
Archon that looks pretty cool and then
in Diablo you're also getting another
pet looks like a little pro pet and some
armored trans blogs going down the list
are stone dip they've got so many
properties now hearthstone you're gonna
get this kind of cool Starcraft 2 legacy
of the void card back
and finally and heroes of the storm
you're gonna get a looks like a little
almost like a Silver Surfer type of
mount so that's pretty cool yeah that's
what you can kind of expect in the
collector's edition box looks pretty
cool and yeah tell me if you guys are
gonna get a collector's edition
Starcraft 2 legacy of the void game here
or if you're even gonna still play
Starcraft 2 good game for you head games
for you leave it in the comments below
and stay tuned the gamespot.com for more
covered
[Music]
you